عبد السلام كيف تبدو الاوضاع في اليوم
الخامس من عمليه طوفان الاقصى يمكن الحديث
الان عن اربع محاور نتحدث اولا عن قطاع
غزه ارتفع عدد الشهداء الى 1055 شهيدا حتى
هذه اللحظه مع ارتفاع ايضا عدد المصابين
والجرحى الى 5000 وارتفاع ايضا التكلفه
الانسانيه فيما يتعلق باثار الحصار الذي
تم فرضه على القطاع وهناك ترقب لانقطاع
كامل للكهرباء وايضا ل بدء نفاد الم مخزون
الغذائي وايضا مخزون المياه مما يعارض كما
يقول المراقبون والمتابعون وحتى الامم
المتحده بانه يخالف القانون الدولي اذا
انه يتم معاقبه المدنيين بفعل بسبب فعل لم
يرتكبوه اساسا في مخالفه واضحه للقانون
الدولي لكن في المقابل هناك استهدافات
مباشره للفصائل الفلسطينيه في العمق
الاسرائيلي استهدفت ديروت اسدود ووصلت حتى
تل ابيب وت عطلت حركه الملاحه لفتره وجيزه
في مطار بين جوريون بعد ان دوت صافرات
الانذار في تل ابيب واعلنت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه انها استهدفت مطار بين جوريون
تحديدا الجانب الاسرائيلي حتى الان يعلن
ان عدد القتلى في عمليه طوفان الاقصى وصل
الى 1200 قتيل من الجانب الاسرائيلي يمكن
ان نتحدث ايضا عن التوتر على الحدود
الشماليه الاسرائيليه حيث كان هناك
اشتباكات بين بعض العناصر في الجانب
اللبناني مع القوات الاسرائيليه على
الحدود وكان هناك تحذيرات من ازدياد
التوتر في هذه المنطقه وهناك اتصالات
دوليه عديده في محاوله لخفض التوتر في تلك
المناطق ايضا لاحظنا في الساعات الاخيره
ان هناك دعم مفتوح للجانب الاسرائيلي بدا
ظاهرا من التصريحات الرسميه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي ارسلت حامله
الطائرات الى السواحل الاسرائيليه وايضا
هناك وفد يرتقب ان يصل الى تل ابيب من
المسؤولين الامريكيين بينما وصل وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني بالفعل الى تل ابيب
هناك ايضا محور نتحدث عنه هو الدعم
الخارجي الشعبي هناك دعم من قبل كثير من
الدول فيما يتعلق بدعم القضيه الفلسطينيه
خرجت مهرا في عدد من الدول مما ترتب عليه
رد فعل ايضا في الدول الاوروبيه هناك بعض
الدول تفكر في حظر رفع العلم الفلسطيني
هناك مظاهرات جوبهت بالقوه كما حصل في
باريس ونترقب في الساعات الاخيره تطورات
عديده فيما يتعلق بالوضع الانساني نعود
الى قطاع غزه وردود الفعل على هذه
التحذيرات القادمه من الداخل من الناحيه
الصحيه ومن ناحيه الغذاء والدواء m